à quelques mètres du décor de carte
postale on embauche
invité par l'association allait virer
ces agents pôle emploi supervise près de
90 postes à pourvoir des emplois que les
postulants pourront décrocher grâce à un
job dating totalement numérique
une formule dictée par la conjoncture
mais qui donne des idées pour l'avenir
c'est un recrutement qui est rapide qui
est précis et puis aujourd'hui par
rapport à la crise sanitaire on est
obligé de passer par le digital
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
s'inscrire dans la durée absolument
parce qu'aujourd'hui les gros clients
vont pouvoir avoir des entretiens en
visio ils pourront se connecter
rapidement avec en même temps que le
candidat et avoir soit un entretien en
visio swan entretien part au chat
c'est-à-dire sms ou un entretien par
téléphone
la formule permet aussi aux martiniquais
expatriés de postuler des candidats au
retour qui finiront peut-être lauréats
des virées de l'année il son
kinésithérapeute restaurateurs ou
agriculteurs et ont choisi de rentrer
participer au développement du pays mis
à l'honneur par l'association allait
virer
il rappelle que l'herbe n'est pas
forcément plus verte ailleurs
parce qu'on a tous le même processus on
parle se former on part une fois qu'on
est qualifié il faut avoir aussi sept
des 20 jeux se dire qu'est ce que peut
apporter à notre île
quelle plus value et quelles valeurs on
va rapporter chez nice
tous mes amis qui ont passé ce stade des
dix ans c'est assez compliqué on en
parle j'essaie de les motiver leur dire
de rentrer parce que la vie est belle
qu'on se le dise la vie est belle un
scénic et c'est ce que je véhicule
le point commun à tous ces nominés c'est
qu'ils sont animés par une seule et même
chassé l'on vit un moment où notre
retour au pays pour des raisons qu'elle
quelle soit envie de retrouver la
famille marc delzescaux sensation de ne
pas être chez soi le numérique comme un
outil au service d'un retour au pays une
nécessité dans une île où la démographie
est en chute libre et certains secteurs
peinent à trouver des postulants
martiniquais